de quoi va-t-on parler aujourd'hui chez
un ami me 11 que j'ai récupéré hier dire
reçu récupérer et à chercher directement
chez chuo oui et on en a profité pour
faire un podcast que je vous diffuse
d'ici quelques jours dans fréquence
greuze vous aimez le lien en bas à la
description les jeter une oreille sur
podcast pas les yeux mais une oreille
vous allez voir c'est intéressant on
apprend plein de belles choses sur chien
au mieux on apprend plein de belles
choses sur ce produit c'est super
intéressant pas vous ai tout dit donc on
va se parler aujourd'hui de ce
smartphone ont regardé s'il intéresse on
va le boxer c'est la première que ce
qu'on va faire c'est l'exercice je n'ai
pas ouvertes voulait vraiment le faire
avec vous on va donc se l'ouvrir on va
regarder comment les faits première
impression qu est ce que j'en pense
c'est ce qu'il me paraît intéressant de
regarder un peu la fiche technique voir
quel usage on va pouvoir avant derrière
et surtout est-ce que ce million se peut
potentiellement être intéressant tout en
sachant que ce million on va se faire le
test d'ici quelques jours le temps que
j'apprenne à l' domestique et qu'on
redevienne potes ou pas allez savoir
donc aujourd'hui céline boxing day 11
[Musique]
regardez-moi ça alors là bas tu es ste
c'est épuré effectivement va pas grand
chose par contre ce qu'on voit c'est
marqué tout envahi si je peux si vous
les lisez bien son par harman kardon
effectivement là cinq jeunes a les
éléments les plus importants et nous le
met ici aussi en argument c'est juste là
c'est la caméra sans 8 mégapixels pour
la botte après c'est un très très gros
standards chez chiron me bats tout de
suite ce l'ouvrir pour chiots me on nous
a dit s attend d europe
bon ça c'est l'emballage du modèle
presse ok c'est grâce à sa très très
grande
plutôt sympa pas mal du tout on va
s'organiser dans quelques instants on
regarde ce qui est intérieure la boîte
on trouve ici un bloc de chartres est
lourd vache par sage et vous emparer
dans quelques instants c'est un bloc de
charge qui change très vite
a priori donc ça on se regarde un peu
plus tard j'aime bien ce système de
modules photo au cochon ça assez
différent est assez sympa j'aime bien
l'idée d'avoir intégré leur capteur
principal comme ça le rôle ovale cette
espèce de foccart et tout ça se mélange
plutôt bien ça crée une asymétrie qui
assez mal ils ont poussé sur le côté il
est grand ou là les thèmes relatifs
morand on voit qu'on a des bords
incurvés qui vont être là pour améliorer
la prise en main je tiens plutôt bien on
a deux l'infrarouge une houle marquise
il a une fiche de 6-10 et bien c'est son
avec harman kardon que vous retrouvez
ici votre haut-parleurs qui s'y tient
c'est une des particularités de ce
modèle si vous avez un haut parleur qui
situe là et le deuxième se situe en bas
pourra vraiment une expérience de stéréo
de phase avec le son qui sort exactement
de la même manière de droite et de
gauche le titre décoché ici au niveau
des boutons de volume est due to run off
ou l'usb ci dessous le tiroir de cartes
sim là ici c'est un verre corning
gorilla glass invictus qui va être la
toute dernière mouture de verre corning
gorilla glass résistant plutôt bien et
il existe en deux finitions c1 finition
givré antireflet ça c'est le bleu
horizon existe également en bleu de
minuit
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui a
réalisé en partenariat avec rideau chine
et tenez vous bien j'ai une très bonne
nouvelle pour vous c'est la première
fois que rino chine
là vous fabriquez des coques pour un
modèle de shiao vie et ça commence avec
le million en servir protéger votre
millions ce grâce à une coque de rhinau
shield et nos chiffres fabrique la coque
différentes plein de modèles différents
je vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description les coques vont arriver
vouloir vous inscrire pour être tenu au
courant pour être informés les premiers
informés dès que les com de rhinau chic
venir arrivée sur notre chèr mi mai 11
c'est pour bientôt c'est pour très
bientôt
pensez donc venir à vous inscrire via le
lien que vous avez en main description
henry dauchy fabrique des coques des
crashs garder protection des protections
d'écran et plein de protection plein
d'objets hyper intéressant pour vos
smartphones venir trouver différentes
collections notamment aux couleurs de
fortes night hunter hunter la nba
également des coques approuvé par la
nasa y en a pour tout le monde pour tous
les univers vous invite donc à venir
cliquez sur le lien en bas dans la
description pour tout savoir sur sa
cokerie nos chiffres pour votre chien
omis millions ce parce que oui pour un
très joli smartphone c'est bien les
venir le protéger c'est encore mieux
même si vous avez un cordon de gorilla
glass dictus ces liens mais s'il tombait
s'il tombe mal voilà pas non plus la
magie pensez donc à mettre une jolie
coque du sud une fois de plus je vous
renvoie aux liens en bas dans la
description jeu tout juste de l'allumer
j'aime bien en tout cas l'idée d'avoir
un écran incurvé qui sur le côté je sais
pas si vous le verrez bien on a un écran
qui a curve est en fait sur le côté je
le connais pas particulièrement donc
c'est vraiment de la vraiment vraiment
première découverte je les appelle à lui
mais j'ai pas fait encore de mise à jour
c'est qu'ici vous êtes donc soit un mode
sombre soit un mode casas et me wade 12
me wade où ça marche bien j'en ai déjà
parlé dans une précédente vidéo vous
avez un écran peut monter jusqu en wqs
des plus ça s'est super bien 3200 par
1440 sinon full hd plus si vous le
souhaitez pour les menhirs économiser la
batterie siècle au wqs des plus assez
marrante au rafraîchissement peut monter
jusqu'à 120 hertz 120 hertz est
compatible avec le wqs des plus donc on
peut faire les deux ça c'est vachement
bien scindé crans une dalle amoled un
qui dit amoled l'écran samsung cl80 1
pouces on a des couleurs 18 vous avez un
taux d'échantillonnage tactile de 480 m
ça c'est plutôt intéressant aussi je
vous le disais le son stéréo harman
kardon cent respectivement on parlait
bien évidemment lors du test et c'est
moi le temps vraiment bien
estelle découverte tous les côtés j'ai
en plus du bluetooth 5.2 pour revenir à
péret un casque sans fil
la performance est extrêmement important
alors je sais pas si vous vous
intéressez à l'univers du smartphone au
côté fiche technique à comprendre
réellement ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
son smartphone eh bien il faut savoir
qu'ici le million c'est le tout premier
smartphone équipé du processeur de
qualcomm le snapdragon 888 le dernier
modèle le plus haut de gamme de qualcomm
aujourd'hui qualcomm et le leader au
niveau des processeurs de smartphones et
shlomi le tout premier intégrer cette
plus ici dans son million c'est donc la
première fois que je vais venir
découvrir cette puce ce qualcomm
snapdragon 888 côté graphique vous avez
une adreno 660 vous avez le dernier
modem également son objet de qualcomm
c'est le x 60
on a donc ici une fiche technique qui
fait baver qui donne très envie à voir
et évidemment à l' usage s'il tient ses
promesses ou pas vous avez 8 gigas de
ram c'est la lpddr2 5 à 3200 mégahertz
ce qui vous apportera plus de fluidité
dans ça chantait si vous avez deux
configurations 68 il ya le stockage 3
256 giga de stockage on va retrouver
intérieur une grosse batterie de 4600
milliampères heures et surtout est ce
qui est extrêmement intéressant vous
avez de la recharge rapide 55 watts
ok why not mais surtout vous avez de la
recharge sans fil 50 watts recharge sans
fil 50 watts normalement les recharge
sans fil ne vont pas aussi vite
là vous avez une charge sans fil qui en
tout cas l'air extrêmement intéressante
alors ici vous n'avez pas dans la boîte
de charger son fils inclus va falloir
dire l'acheter séparément par contre
shiomi a conservé son chargeur à
l'intérieur vous avez donc un bob denard
de 55 watts qui est inclus il faut
savoir également que vous avez de la
recharge inversée d'iwate si vous voulez
venir recharger des écouteurs vous
pourquoi pas transférer l'énergie à 9
smartphones toute la partie logiciel
sensiwave 12h me wade douche vous le dis
une fois de plus on est déjà parlé là
j'ai activé le tiroir d'applications
jeux vous êtes obligés comme pas obligé
de le mettre
colette si vous le souhaitez moi j'aime
bien informés de tout regrouper ces
pratiques et aussi la navigation par
gestes vous avoir tous vos raccourcis
sur le haut
très complet moi j'aime bien
l'expérience je trouve vraiment bien que
je suis au mit vraiment monter en gamme
là dessus donc si vous cherchez une
expérience sur android qui est clair et
qui est lisible pour moi me wade 12 pas
très bien le staff
maintenant le gros focus qui est fait
ici par shiomi sur toute la partie photo
vous le voyez vous est pas moins de
trois capteurs à l'arrière 3 enfin deux
gros et un tout petit en fait vous avez
un capteur principal c'est un capteur de
100 8 mégapixels je mets au centre qui
est juste là j'ai pas plus d'artistes
tutoie la fiche technique on a parlé un
peu plus tard on en soit 1 13 mégapixels
c'est un nul tra grand temps qu'on ne
parle aussi dans quelques jours et là
j'ai ce qu'ils appellent le thé les
maquereaux c'est de la macro cdu 5
mégapixels
on verra le test dont david est
maintenant bien vous abonner pour tout
savoir un petit flash led et puis avant
vous avez une petite caméra de cette
fille est planqué ici vous l'avez juste
là là c'est une caméra de celle fille de
20 méga pixels donc on s'en reparlera ça
aussi des évidemment d'ici quelques
jours
j'aime bien et je le vois tout de suite
c'est que toute la partie photo vient
occuper toute la partie de mon écran je
sois vraiment très simple très lisible
tu peux bien monter jusqu'en x 30 ha
ouais on regardera ça j'ai mon
ultra-grand-angle là je passe sur ma
caméra de celle-ci coucou je suis juste
là la partie vidéo qui aussi
intéressante on peut venir filmer
jusqu'à huit cas d'un point de vue
logiciel sont bien bien bien bossé on
peut faire de la 8 cas jusqu'à 30 images
par secondes ça c'est bien parce que
chez cinq sont ces deux-là 8 à 24 images
par seconde après aujourd'hui je suis
pas sur combien de films dont 8,4 venir
comparer 24 30 fps là dessus bord alors
extrêmement intéressante au 15 mai la 4k
en 60 images par secondes ça c'est bien
il ya plein de petits mode super macro
en vidéo on va voir la grille on peut
venir redresser c'est pas mal plein de
petites fonctionnalités logicielles qui
ont l'air bien une participation la
stabilisation ça j'imagine stabilisation
vidéo ok et si je push là tu vas voir
l'installation vidéo pro moi j'aime bien
en tout cas prise en main est plutôt
sympa le format est bien le smartphone
est jolie la recharge et rapide
voilà pour moi un très beau boulot une
fois de plus j'ai hâte de voir le
résultat lors du test d'ici quelques
jours vous pouvez insérer deux cartes
sim intérieur vous avez du nlc notamment
pour le paiement des matériels et en
tout cas ça sera femme qu'elle fiche
technique est extrêmement robuste shiomi
montre les muscles mais on peut aller
plus loin pourquoi parce qu'au niveau de
la configuration est en voie notamment
au niveau de la photo vous avez capteur
principal sur maps et si le grand temps
où on va avoir une ultra grand-angle et
on a de la macro on a donc
qui ment trois objectifs mais aura été y
en a deux qui sont intéressantes puisque
la macro pour moi on la baisse août aps
pas grand chose d'ailleurs dit moi si un
objectif télé macro ça peut vous
intéresser ou pas ce qui serait
extrêmement pertinent c'est d'avoir un
objectif à pas pour avoir un vrai beau
téléobjectif et pourquoi pas un zoom
périscopique pour venir chercher loin de
l'image donc ça me laisse penser qu'on
devrait potentiellement voir arriver un
mis aux pros sur le marché pourquoi
parce que ça serait intéressant ça irait
dans le sens de l'histoire
on n'ira dire plus loin en termes de
performances ont pour elles un peu plus
loin en apportant plus de visiter car un
peu plus de ram pourquoi pas monter
jusqu'à 12 voire 16 giga de ram ça ça me
semblerait assez intéressant autres tel
qu'on le voit ici celui oms il fait de
belles promesses notamment la
performance en écran qu'à l'air
extrêmement intéressant à voir bien
évidemment que soit le rang du niveau
des photos le rendu au niveau de la
vidéo sans lampard effectivement une
fois de plus dans le podcast parce que
oui j'ai trouvé pierre-alain voir qui
est le directeur marketing de xiaoli
france et qui nous paraît effectivement
de très belles capacités en vidéo une
fois de plus je vous laisse
envoyez vos oreilles 20 de podcasts le
lien est en bas dans la description
aucun smartphone qui fait de très très
belles promesses qui en tout cas semble
les tenir en partie avoir bien
évidemment dans quelques jours lors du
têt dont vous invite dès maintenant à
venir vous abonner si ce n'est pas
toujours le câble des petits boutons
rouges qui est là là quelque part en
tout si les rouges si vous n'êtes pas
abonné cliquez sur le bouton rouge
activer la cloche comme ça vous serez
notifié qu'une prochaine vidéo arrivera
et ça s'est vraiment bien le cas
smartphones que faute plutôt coucher
hormis continuera à porter de nouvelles
et par chardy continuent à faire évoluer
sa gamme jeu de rendez-vous est
évidemment très très très prochainement
parce qu'on n'a toujours pas les tarifs
et les disponibilités il ya eu le
lancement global de ce smartphone ce qui
me permet de vous présenter aujourd'hui
par contre le lancement france se fera
le 16 février donc je ne sais pas quel
moment vous regardez cette vidéo et
publiée en tout cas avant le 16 février
donc si vous la regardez
après 16 février eh bien on connaît les
tarifs on connaît la dispense met alors
à laquelle je la tourne veulent
absolument aucune information de tarif
ni de disponibilité donc ce rendez vous
dans quelques jours et on compare
effectivement du résultat lors du test
vous dire ce que j'en ai pensé sur un
usage quotidien usage régulier
on regardera si les promesses sont
tenues en vidéo grâce et les promesses
sont tenues en photo on verra s'il est
intéressant au niveau de l'écran vers à
l'expérience audio et dernière j'avais
beaucoup aimé l'expérience audio sur les
midis ces milices prod avait une très
belle expérience de stéréoscopie
je veux ça vraiment vraiment vraiment
intéressant à voir cette année on va
retrouver la vraie vie
ici sur le million d'hommes donc on
tenait simon à deux configurations 8
gigas de ram 128 giga de stockage 8
gigas de ram 256 go de stockage à vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez quoi
vous trouvez vous ce chien 8 millions
c'est ce qu'elle pourrait vous tentez ce
que vous avez acheté le lui dise la
dernière ils disent pro pourquoi pas aux
oiseaux smartphone déchirure ailleurs
dit moi tout de suite quel smartphone
vous avez en bas en commentaire et dites
moi si ce modèle là pourrait vous tente
et bien évidemment on va attendre le
résultat dans quelques jours et ya peu
qui est assez intéressant c'est que le
smartphone n'est toujours pas disponible
tout de suite en tout cas
en france on peut pas le précommander il
n'a pas été présenté il est non pas tout
de suite à l'heure à laquelle de tourner
cette vidéo disponible sur le site de
shion france
absolument pas par contre on peut le
trouver sur certaines marketplace je
pense d exemplaires qui viennent de
chine
vous aimez le lien en bas dans la
description si vous voulez la voir dès
maintenant je vous conseille d'attendre
vous conseille d'attendre la
disponibilité en france
naissances le provincial version
française pour avoir la garantie
garantie française garanties européennes
c'est extrêmement intéressant mais si
vous voulez jeter un petit oeil souhaite
un des premières des early adopters sur
ce modèle là et bien vous pouvez trouvez
vous aimez le lien dans la description
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on va
voir beaucoup d'amour des bisous des
pains au chocolat et connaissez-vous
très vite ciao